années passées à la tête du fonds
monétaire international si le mariage
vous effraie rassurez vous il n'y a plus
d'obstacle à l'entrée en vigueur du pacs
le conseil constitutionnel a jugé
conforme à la constitution tout en
émettant quelques réserves elisabeth
guigou se réjouit espère que le premier
pacte civil de solidarité sera signé
avant la fin de l'année satisfaction
aussi du collectif pour le pacs qui
salue à la fois un choix politique est
une innovation juridique et bing goldman
le conseil constitutionnel a déclaré les
dispositions qui lui étaient déférée
conforme à la constitution
saisi par 213 députés d'opposition et
115 sénateurs le conseil constitutionnel
a donc tranché la loi sur le pacs n'est
donc pas en désaccord avec les principes
de la constitution
mais le conseil a émis quelques réserves
ainsi il rappelle notamment que seuls
les couples hétéros pourront bénéficier
de l'aide médicale à la procréation
assistée
cette décision met fin à dix ans de
controverses d'hésitations et de
violents échanges dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée celle qui fut la plus
acharnée contre le pacs christine boutin
ne s'avoue pas encore vaincu
pour l'instant ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir ce que va faire président de
la république jeudi kyla l'article 10
qui vous donne la possibilité de faire
appel à au parlement pour une nouvelle
délibération
je demande solennellement frito lay
public du z et ce pouvoir
constitutionnel que lui donne l'article
beau joueur le porte-parole de
démocratie libérale a simplement
regretté cette décision je suis très
triste de voir qu'on impose à la société
un française un texte sur le plan des
principes aussi dangereux aussi inutiles
et aussi mal monté sur le plan juridique
je le regrette profondément à gauche le
réseau reese me sens et on pense déjà à
la suite devrait pouvoir enregistrer les
premiers plein axe maintenant très
rapidement et peut être d'ici la fin de
l'année
c'est désormais au président de la
république de promulguer la loi et le
projet de loi sur la parité hommes
femmes en politique sera présente